termes économiques l'espace et est
devenu un lieu de confrontation
potentiel je pense que militarisation ça
veut dire que finalement il ya un risque
pour assister à une guerre dans les oui
la guerre est possible il ya de
multiples façons d'amener de rendre
inopérant effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
les contaminations sont repartis à la
hausse en france le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand redoutent vingt mille
cas par jour début août si nous
n'agissons pas selon ses mots face au
risque d'une quatrième vague emmanuel
macron s'adressera aux français demain
soir renforcement du pacte sanitaires et
vaccinations obligatoires sont à l'étude
[Musique]
l'europe est la région la plus touchée
par cette forme épidémique certains pays
prennent donc de nouvelles restrictions
pour contenir la propagation du variant
delta malte ferme ainsi ses frontières
aux non vaccinés et tant pis pour le
pass à lithaire décidé au sort mieux
le secrétaire d'état français aux
affaires européennes clément bonne
dénonce une décision contraire aux
règles européennes
[Musique]
martin d'oydes déclare vouloir
poursuivre la bataille de son mari la
veuve du président haïtien je venais
louise assassiné par balles mercredi
s'est exprimé sur les réseaux sociaux
météores nasdaq elle n'avait encore pas
pris la parole cet attentat bon je le
pays déjà fragile dans le chaos
la crise institutionnelle s'aggrave les
détails dans ce journal
[Musique]
d
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france a le variant
dalta poursuit sa progression en france
les contaminations repartent à la hausse
près de 4700 cas en 24 heures pour
l'instant pas d'incidence sur la charge
hospitalière mais le gouvernement est en
alerte
un mot d'ordre la vaccination et pour
accélérer la campagne laisse des centres
vont être créée et dédiée aux
fonctionnaires vaccination qui pourrait
être rendu obligatoire pour les
soignants emmanuel macron pourrait se
prononcer sur le sujet demain quand un
voeckler pour la huitième fois en 16
mois
emmanuel macron s'adressera aux français
ce lundi à 20 heures
et une fois n'est pas coutume le
président français évoquera la situation
épidémiologique dans l'hexagone une
déclaration officielle qui suscite de
nombreuses interrogations notamment
celle sur l'obligation vaccinale des
professionnels de santé
jeudi le gouvernement n'a pas hésité à
sortir les phrases chocs pour promouvoir
la vaccination
le vaccin il les protège à 95% des
formes graves
par contre je les protège à 100% du
confinement c'est dire que si tout le
monde est vaccinée on n'aura plus à se
poser la question de savoir si nos
restaurants nos bars nos commerces et
des universités
peuvent rester ouverte dans la durée il
faut qu'on atteigne l'immunité
collective et donc se vacciner c'est un
petit pas pour soi mais c'est un grand
pas pour l'immunité pour faire en sorte
qu'on n'ait plus à subir ces contraintes
et pour que cette épidémie soit derrière
nous la vaccination est l'élément
primordial dans la lutte contre le coc
vide alors que la menace d'une quatrième
vague se fait de plus en plus pressante
les injections de sérum anti kovic et
des soignants sont jugées insuffisantes
par le gouvernement selon santé publique
france près de 50 % des professionnels
de santé en ehpad avait complété leur
schéma vaccinal au 6 juillet 2021
mercredi olivier ferrand a reçu les
syndicats de santé
une déclaration pour encourager la
vaccination chez les soignants a été
signé les syndicats s'engagent même allé
jusqu à l'obligation vaccinale si la
situation le demande
nous espérons que cette déclaration
commune encouragera les soignants et les
personnels l'un d'eux des ehpad des
secteurs sanitaires des secteurs de
l'aide à domicile à aller vers la
vaccination sur un vaccin obligatoire
quand il n'est pas respecté
l'employeur peut recourir au
licenciement ce qui nous cause réelle et
sérieuse donc nous avons été jusqu'à
cette perspective
évidemment nous n'avons pas du tout
envie d'aller jusque là mais si la
vaccination obligatoire et mise en
oeuvre bien sûr il faudra en assumer
toutes les conséquences
le conseil scientifique s'est également
positionné en faveur de cette mesure ce
vendredi un projet de loi pourrait être
adopté d'ici la fin du mois
l'obligation vaccinale pourrait
concerner tous les professionnels de
santé
mais pas seulement l'élargissement de
cette mesure à l'ensemble des
professions en contact avec du public
est actuellement à l'étude
emmanuel macron devrait aussi faire le
point sur certaines réformes laissées en
suspens en raison de la crise sanitaire
parmi elles l'objectif de supprimer et
50 mille postes de fonctionnaires est
elle fâche
cent vingt mille postes dans la fonction
publique emmanuel macron s'était engagé
à réduire de manière drastique le nombre
de fonctionnaires lorsqu'il était le
candidat dans marche
cinquante mille postes de fonctionnaires
d'état devaient être supprimés durant
son quinquennat
ainsi que 70 mille postes dans la
fonction publique territoriale
à moins d'un an de la fin du mandat du
chef de l'état l'objectif a été
totalement abandonnée
interviewé sur la web télé acteurs
publics le ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics a confirmé le changement
de cap il y a eu un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises après le
grand débat en 2019 qui nous ont amenés
à revoir ses objectifs au delà des
décisions que nous avons prises après le
grand débat la crise s'est abattue sur
le pays et cela s'est traduit par des
créations de postes parce qu'il fallait
y répondre
toutes ces décisions nous les assumons
cela fait partie des réponses à la crise
et cela a modifié évidemment l'objectif
à l'échelle du quinquennat
nous avons collectivement avec le
premier ministre ou son autorité sous
l'autorité du président de la république
un objectif de stabilité des schémas
d'emplois à l'échelle du quinquennat
entre 2017 et 2022
un changement de cap déjà esquissé par
le chef de l'état lors de sa conférence
de presse d'après grand débat en 2019
j'assume totalement d'abandonner cet
objectif s'il n'est pas tenable de base
ces suppressions devait participer à la
réduction de la dépense publique de 3
points de pib comme le souhaitait et
emmanuel macron à gauche cet abandon est
plutôt bien accueillie maintenir cet
objectif aurait été criminel indique le
secrétaire national du pcf est candidat
à la présidentielle fabien roussel à nos
confrères du monde
à droite en revanche on ne déplore comme
le rapporte le quotidien
pour la vice-présidente lr annie
genevard cette volonté de réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires n'a jamais été
véritablement là puisque très peu de
suppressions de postes sont intervenus
avant la crise ce point n'est pas le
seul sur lequel emmanuel macron a fait
marche arrière parmi les sujets de recul
on peut citer l'interdiction du
glyphosate ou la limitation de vitesse à
80 km/heure et dernier rétropédalage en
date le référendum sur la réforme
constitutionnelle ayant pour but
d'inscrire la préservation de
l'environnement à l'article 1er de la
constitution
il n'aura finalement pas lieu emmanuel
macron s'était pourtant engagé à le
mettre en oeuvre
l'europe est la région du monde où la
pandémie a le plus progressé cette
semaine à l'échelle du continent le
nombre de nouveaux cas a augmenté de 34%
en sept jours particulièrement touché le
portugal l'espagne ou encore la grèce
des destinations très prisées des
vacanciers alors pour contenir la
nouvelle vague certains états a opté
pour des mesures drastiques malte ferme
ainsi ses frontières aux voyageurs non
vaccinés contraire aux règles
européennes réplique le secrétaire
d'état français aux affaires européennes
clément bonne plus réussis de florian
lambert
à l'heure d'une vague de départs en
vacances partout en europe la situation
sanitaire inquiète de plus en plus en
haut lieu
paradoxalement les européens peuvent de
nouveau profiter d'une vie normale
durant cette période estivale
en retrouvant les discothèques bars et
restaurants pourtant la pandémie regagne
du terrain partout en europe la région
du monde où la recrudescence de nouveaux
cas est la plus forte avec une hausse de
34% de nouveaux cas conséquence certains
pays comme les pays bas ont d'ores et
déjà annoncé une série de mesures comme
la fermeture des boîtes de nuit pour
contrer une flambée de contamination
coronavirus il est clair que nous devons
ralentir la propagation du virus
et c'est pourquoi nous avons dû décider
aujourd'hui de durcir les mesures
actuelles sur certains points dans le
but de freiner la propagation du virus
de protéger les plus vulnérables et de
gérer la pression sur les soins de santé
selon une étude belge la moitié des
contaminations européenne serait dû aux
vacanciers partis à l'étranger notamment
dans le sud de l'europe
destination touristique prisée par les
européens la grèce le portugal ou encore
l'espagne sont les pays où le variant
delta circule le plus en grèce 1400 cas
sont décomptés chaque jour soit une
augmentation du nombre de contaminations
de 200% la situation royaume uni est
également tendue pour la première fois
depuis janvier le pays des crêtes plus
de 35000 contamination quotidien
yoko vite 19 pourtant dans le même temps
l'union européenne annonce avoir atteint
son objectif d'obtenir assez de doses
pour vacciner 70 % de sa population
adulte l'union européenne a tenu parole
ce week end nous avons livré
suffisamment de vaccins aux états
membres pour être en mesure de vacciner
complètement au moins 70 % des adultes
de lieux encore ce mois ci d'ici demain
quelques 500 millions de doses auront
été distribués l'union européenne tient
donc parole c'est donc une course à la
vaccination qui se joue en europe à
l'heure où la propagation rapide du
variant delta et le relâchement des
gestes barrières risque de mettre l'été
sous cloche et l'euro de football est
soupçonné d'avoir participé à cette
propagation du variant delta à travers
l'europe la compétition s'est toutefois
poursuivie et la finale italie
angleterre a lieu ce soir à londres en
présence de spectateurs
ambiance tendue autour de wembley à l
approche du coup d'envoi plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de supporteurs
anglais sont rassemblés autour du stade
depuis à la matinée certains éméché
jetant des projectiles des supporters
sans billets ont forcé des barrières
pour se rapprocher du stade les
spectateurs en revanche tenus à distance
des jeux olympiques de tokyo dans
quelques semaines
le japon a choisi lui d'organiser la
compétition essentiellement à huis clos
quentin dont claire clément ned delcourt
des tribunes vides et qui le resteront
pour la première fois de l'histoire des
jeux olympiques se dérouleront à huis
clos décision jeudi du gouvernement
japonais en raison d'un nouveau regain
épidémique dans la capitale un choix qui
s'ajoute à la mise en place d'un nouvel
état d'urgence dans l'agglomération de
tokyo
les jeux de tokyo devait être une
occasion rare de ressentir la puissance
du sport à travers des stades pleins et
des communautés unis cependant c'est
avec regret qu'ils doivent maintenant
être organisée de manière très limitée
en raison de la propagation du nouveau
cours aux navires us
salette à comtois je suis vraiment
désolé pour les fans qui ont acheté les
billets et attendait les jeux avec
impatience ans que pour la population
locale
lima la capitale nippone en état
d'urgence jusqu'au 22 août prochain
outre tokyo
les compétitions se déroulant dans trois
autres départements du pays seront
également interdites au public
le premier ministre japonais gardent
espoir d'assouplir les restrictions si
la situation s'améliore si nous
constatons une diminution du nombre de
lits occupés par les patients atteints
du coronavirus jeu pourrait raccourcir
la période de l'état d'urgence la
tendance ne va pour autant pas dans ce
sens la vaccination peine à trouver son
rythme
seulement 15% des japonais sont
entièrement vacciner concernant le
nombre moyen de nouveaux cas quotidiens
il a atteint les 1500 contre à peine
1000 sur la même période l'an passé
la propagation du vaillant delta fait
également craindre l'apparition d'une
nouvelle vague dans le pays
le nombre de nouveaux cas continuent
d'augmenter à tokyo avec l'augmentation
des déplacements de personnes le variant
delta plus infectieux représente
désormais environ 30 % des cas
ce chiffre devrait encore augmenter la
réinstauration de l'état d'urgence aura
des conséquences directes sur l'économie
au sein de l'agglomération la vente
d'alcool sera limité les bars et
restaurants fermeront plus tôt les jeux
olympiques débuteront donc le 23 juillet
dans un contexte tendu puisque la tenue
de l'événement est de plus en plus mal
perçue par une partie de la population
des jo
d'ores et déjà surnommé les jeux de la
pandémie
elle sera mise en oeuvre dès 2023 la
réforme fiscale mondiale au terme de
deux jours de tractations a venise les
ministres des finances des pays du g20
ont donné leur feu vert pour la création
d'un impôt minimum international d'au
moins 15% sur les multinationales
historique pour certains insuffisant
pour d'autres explications grâce
d'ailleurs mettre fin aux paradis
fiscaux
c'est l'objectif de la réforme de la
taxation des multinationales approuvé
par le g20 à venise une réforme qui
ouvre la voie à une véritable révolution
fiscale
l'accord du g20 est une réalisation
importante qui contribuera à stabiliser
le système fiscal international dans les
années à venir
il offrira une plus grande sécurité
fiscale et mettra fin la course vers le
bas en ce qui concerne les taux
d'imposition des sociétés
ce plan prévoit une imposition d'au
moins 15% sur les bénéfices des grandes
multinationales pour éviter qu'elle
n'échappe à leurs obligations fiscales
approuvé par 132 pays
la réforme menée sous l'égide de l'osce
et d eux devraient voir le jour en 2023
mais pour ces manifestants rassemblés
sous les fenêtres des grands argentiers
de la planète
il en faudra beaucoup plus pour réduire
les inégalités dans le monde
les choix économiques et financiers du
g20 ont des conséquences sur nos vies
sous de nombreuses formes par exemple
sur notre droit aux soins de santé
nous l'avons vu avec le co vide sur la
redistribution des richesses
ils ont des conséquences sur les droits
des travailleurs et sur la crise
environnementale et climatique
donc aujourd'hui en tant que groupe uni
nous demandons que toute la richesse qui
est détenu par une très petite partie de
la population soit redistribuée de
manière plus juste
ils sont l'emblème d'un modèle de
fonctionnement des processus
décisionnels et démocratique qui n'en
est pas vraiment un
puis nous sommes complètement exclus des
décisions qui nous concernent et nous
impacte personnellement après avoir été
bloqués par la police des affrontements
ont éclaté entre manifestants et forces
de l'ordre
mise à part la fiscalité d'autres sujets
ont été abordés lors de ce g20 finances
de venise comme la question de
l'inégalité d'accès aux vaccins
l'augmentation de l'aide financière aux
pays les plus pauvres ou encore la
taxation du carbone comme outil de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
quatre jours après l'attentât la
première dame d'haïti martin maurice
prend la parole blessés mercredi par les
assaillants qui ont tué son époux le
président joël moïse
elle appelle à poursuivre la bataille
menée par son mari l'assassinât de son
époux plongeurs un peu plus encore le
pays dans une crise politique et
sécuritaire
robin pu elle la disparition de joe
venail moïse laisse haïti dans le chaos
quelques heures après son assassinat
c'est le premier ministre par intérim
claude joseph qui a décrété l'état de
siège pour au moins 15 jours devenant
dans les faits le dirigeant du pays
une décision contestée par ariel henry
ce dernier venait d'être nommé premier
ministre par jour venail moïse un des
derniers gestes politiques du président
avant sa mort mais il n'avait pas encore
pris ses fonctions ce vendredi l'onu a
pourtant accordé sa confiance à claude
joseph tout en demandant le respect du
plan électoral qui prévoit la tenue
d'élections le 26 septembre ainsi que
dans référendum constitutionnel
le premier ministre haïtien claude
joseph a expliqué que le gouvernement
qui est en place sous sa direction
continue de gouverner jusqu'à ce qu'il y
ait des élections et tout changement à
cette procédure devrait être le résultat
d'un accord politique
deux homme prétend donc dirigé haïti une
crise de gouvernance alors que le pays
est déjà plongé dans une crise
institutionnelle
je venais le moïse n'avait pas organiser
d'élections depuis son arrivée à la tête
du gouvernement début 2000
17 et le pays n'a plus de parlement
depuis janvier 2020 l'opposition accuse
claude joseph d'accaparer le pouvoir
on est dans un autre de qui est terrible
1 pour les ministres qui étaient partis
mais qui n'avait pas encore assisté à
l'installation du second est donc le
second qui a un document appelé mais qui
va aider nos b et il se trouve que le
partant celui qui a été révoqué claude
joseph et retourner sur ses pas aux
règles le pouvoir c'est ça le coup
d'état la situation politique et
institutionnelle instable fait craindre
une aggravation de la crise sécuritaire
qui frappe également le pays
le gouvernement haïtien a demandé à
washington et aux nations unies
d'envoyer des troupes pour sécuriser les
infrastructures vitales comme les ports
les aéroports et les terminaux
pétroliers
une crise politique qui menace les
élections prévues en septembre écoutez
l'analyse de jacques pési politologue
membre du laboratoire caribéen de
sciences sociales
la position de la communauté
internationale
elle est complètement cette michel est
complètement inadapté parce que dans les
conditions actuelles il n'est pas
possible d'organiser des élections en
haïti dans les prochains mois il
faudrait pas s'y fier la société
haïtienne dit des armes illégales les
gangs qui représente une menace
permanente sur la vie quotidienne des
haïtiens au moment où nous parlons les
les quatre départements du pays ne sont
pas accessibles et cela depuis quatre
mois et le gouvernement haïtien et
notamment josé luis était en connivence
avec ses glandes pas soit ils
utilisaient ces gommes comme étant une
ressource de sa survie politique
alors aucune élection n'est possible
aujourd'hui sans passif hissant un
travail de pacification de la société
haïtienne
il ya désormais plus de soldats
australiens en afghanistan le retrait
des troupes s'est fait ces dernières
semaines la fin d'un engagement
militaire de 20 ans dans le pays
fin août fils en sera de même pour les
états unis l'armée afghane se retrouvera
alors seul face à aux talibans qui
affirment contrôler désormais à 85
pour cent du territoire et leurs
offensives se poursuit les forces
régulières auront elles la capacité de
faire face aux insurgés
éléments de réponse avec françoise et
guy lambert c'est une offensive lancée
en mai dernier qui commence à porter ses
fruits pour les talibans peu à peu les
insurgés s'empare de localités face à
une armée afghane qui n'oppose qu'une
faible résistance
sur ces images on peut voir des dizaines
de talibans franchir le poste frontière
d'isla bras la principal point de
passage entre l'afghanistan et l'iran il
se serait aussi emparée de celui de
torun dit à la frontière du turkménistan
le mouvement islamiste tente aussi de
reprendre des villes comme ici à rallye
nos la première capitale provinciale
dans laquelle ils ont réussi à pénétrer
depuis le début de leur offensive
présent à moscou lors d'une conférence
de presse vendredi les représentants des
talibans ont assuré que leur mouvement
contrôlé désormais 85% du territoire
afghan
l'émirat islamique d'afghanistan a des
contacts avec le peuple
ils nous réclament la situation change
si vite
cela signifie que les gens nous
réclament les afghans ont confiance en
nous même si le gouvernement de kaboul
assure pouvoir reprendre le contrôle de
la situation
l'armée afghanes semble démuni sans le
soutien des états unis
on appuie sur lequel les afghans ne
peuvent plus compter alors que
washington accélère le retrait de ses
troupes
elle devrait quitter le pays le 31 août
prochain mettant ainsi un terme à vingt
ans d'intervention militaire américaine
mais ouais nous y sommes allés pour deux
raisons la première pour envoyer oussama
ben laden aux portes de l'enfer comme je
les dis à l'époque chaque jour la
deuxième raison était déguisé la
capacité d'al qaïda à mener d'autres
attaques aux états unis à partir de ce
territoire
nous avons atteint ces deux objectifs
c'est fait dieu sait ce que je pensais
depuis le début pourquoi nous devions
risque est pourquoi nous devions aller
en afghanistan
le travail a été fait depuis un certain
temps c'est pourquoi je pense que ce
retrait est une bonne décision et très
franchement elle était attendue au vu de
le retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan inquiète la russie sergueï
lavrov dit redouter une recrudescence de
la violence dans le pays
la menace d'attaqués terroristes
augmentent en afghanistan les talibans
sont devenus plus hostile parce que
l'accord précédent prévoyez la mise en
place d' autorité intérimaire pour poser
les conditions de structures
gouvernementales plus stable pour faire
face à l'offensive des talibans
plusieurs chefs de guerre se disent
prêts à reprendre les armes pour épauler
l'armée afghane alors que la communauté
internationale redoute une nouvelle
guerre civile en afghanistan les états
unis appelle à un accord politique pour
mettre fin au conflit mais les
négociations lancées il ya plus d'un an
entre kaboul et les talibans n'avance
pas le président afghan a chois fradi
accusent ces derniers de ne pas vouloir
réellement discuté contrairement à leurs
affirmations a longtemps aux adversaires
politiques les deux anciens présidents
de la côte d'ivoire laurent gbagbo et
henri konan bédié se sont affichés unis
ce week-end afin d'oeuvrer à la
réconciliation nationale
de retour dans son pays depuis mi juin
laurent gbagbo a donc été
chaleureusement accueillis par henri
konan bédié une image de complicité et
qui tranche avec les déclarations
hostiles du passé je suis ensemble les
deux hommes se pose aujourd'hui en
opposant à l'actuel chef de l'état
alassane ouattara ils ont souligné
l'urgente nécessité d'oeuvrer pour le
retour d'une paix définitive et durable
en côte d'ivoire écouter
cette reconsidération se fera par une
volonté fois que le chef de l'état
alassane dramane ouattra de tous les
acteurs politiques dont nous sommes la
mise en place d'un nouveau projet
démocratique dans notre pays
désuet de tourette intérêts partisans
par un dialogue franc et sincère seront
la clé du succès
j'ai quoi de tout mon coeur et le prouve
en est arrivé à un simple monsieur le
président richard un mot de ce
rassemblement à paris devant l'ambassade
d'espagne
une centaine de militants la communauté
lgbt se sont réunis pour dénoncer les
violences homophobes pour rendre hommage
aussi à samuel louisien espagnol de 24
ans battu à mort aux abords d'une
discothèque c'était il ya deux semaines
à la corogne dans le nord-ouest de
l'espagne
je vous propose d'écouter ses réactions
les assassinats de lgbt y soit de
lesbiennes de gaye 2 bis de transe d'un
terreau sexe mais ils ont lieu tous les
ans et ils sont très nombreux dans le
monde entier en france on a recensé
aujourd'hui dix assassinats sept années
de pertes de personnes gays et donc nous
on revendique e.on et tué aujourd'hui on
est tabassé pour notre orientation
sexuelle parce qu'on ne rentre pas dans
le schéma hétéronormatif hétérosexuels
et qu'il faut que ça s'arrête tout
simplement
c'est important de montrer qu'il ya une
solidarité internationale aussi que
finalement c'est aux pressions qui sont
vécues par les hommes gays en espagne
bat les i'm gay en france les virus y
aurait évidemment c'est vrai les seules
victimes de l'homophobie et de la
transphobie on pense très fort aux
femmes trans aussi qui sont tués que ce
soit en espagne en france ou partout en
europe mais on constate en plus en ce
moment qui a quand même une
recrudescence de deux lois page constat
la hongrie par exemple qui sont
homophobes et qui vise directement les
minorités de genre et sexuelle et je
pense que ça rapporte ans de montrer
qu'il ya une solidarité internationale
et que les choses elles sont pas isolés
ça se passe pas ses pairs un fait
ponctuel qui s'est passé en espagne
en fait c'est un système qui oppriment
les minorités de genre et sexuelle et
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images à
les conservateurs ou au coude à coude
avec un nouveau parti populiste selon
les sondages à la sortie des bureaux de
vote nouvelles élections législatives
donc en bulgarie les deuxième en trois
mois avec l'espoir que ce scrutin
aboutissent cette fois ci à la formation
d'une coalition
après une décennie de pouvoir du
conservateur à boiko borisov
arrivé en tête du précédent vote
l'ancien premier ministre n'était pas
parvenu à trouver des partenaires
pour gouverner élections législatives
également en moldavie des élections
anticipées convoquées par la nouvelle
présidente pro-européenne maya sens vous
après sa large victoire en novembre 2020
elle espère reprendre le contrôle du
parlement pour mettre en oeuvre la
politique en turquie
douze personnes ont été tuées dans un
accident de bus transportant des
migrants en situation irrégulière 26
autres ont été blessés
l'accident s'est déroulé hier soir à van
dans l'est du pays province frontalière
de l'iran où des dizaines de milliers
d'afghans d'iraniens et deux pakistanais
arrivent chaque année et c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain journal dans une trentaine de
minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
quoi
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés une découverte qui avaient été
faites par des gens qui travaillaient
sur les halles de kb identifié chez les
algues des protéines qui répondent à la
lumière et entraîne la formation d'un
courant électrique comme le font les
neurones et comme le font normalement
les cellules sensibles à la lumière dans
la rétine parce qu'il va dire qu'il voit
un peu ces îles